this week on the boys I don't want to be
someone who leaves people behind I want
to be someone who saves this family you
don't turn it back on family family
family
his friends were all there what a
wonderful surprise the little boy smiled
with joy in his eyes I am your father
[Music]
well we're back after last week's video
was fully demonetized and age restricted
but don't worry this week is all family
friendly he's obviously lying I know
he's lying but before we take a deep
dive into the episode I received a few
comments from viewers that I saved my
references to the teasers and trailers
till the end of the episode so I'll give
you a warning if you don't want to be
spoiled when that section comes up it's
another vnn special news report five
days after the bombshell allegations By
Starlight that soldier boy has returned
Ashley now CEO Avant is in full damage
control and I'm surprised she still has
all her hair she's still Towing the
company line that Maeve is in rehab and
soldier boy died stopping a nuclear
explosion back in 84. she then uses the
platform to smear starlight's
credibility highlighting her
relationship with Kimiko who used to be
part of a terrorist organization known
as The Shining Light Liberation Army the
Chiron touts more lies about Starlight
including her alleged work with a
Hollywood pedal ring a nod to the Q Anon
conspiracy which said a cabal all of
satanic cannibalistic pedophiles in
Hollywood and the Democratic party were
secretly running the U.S government in
episode 4 homelander also mentioned this
group of shadowy figures who secretly
pulled the strings trying to silence him
speaking of homelander you can see an
official statement from him regarding
the incident on vaught's Twitter soldier
boy sings Jimmy Souls if you want to be
happy and there probably isn't a better
song that encapsulates him it's all
about how a pretty wife will make a man
feel small and eventually become his
downfall but an ugly wife will make him
better food and spend most of the time
in the kitchen Stay classy Soldier Boy
The Legend former VP of hero management
at Vaught produced this video Huey
Butcher and Soldier Boy seem to be
crashing at his Cottage in the woods he
tells Huey that soldier boy never really
stormed the beaches at Normandy part of
his job at Vaught was selling this myth
of the American hero and in this way
soldier boy was exploited to advance
this narrative with the cleaning ladies
soldier boy is getting dirty and for you
horn dogs out there this is who the
ledge says has also slept on his bed the
search for Mindstorm one of the payback
soups involved in Soldier Boy's
kidnapping has turned out to be more
difficult than first thought they know
he lives in a secluded cabin somewhere
and that he suffers from bipolar
disorder so if they cross-reference
cabins with pharmacies that sell drugs
that control BPD maybe they can pinpoint
his location Soldier Boy calls Mindstorm
Howard Hughes who you might remember
Leonardo DiCaprio playing in The Aviator
he was one of the richest men in the
world yet died among other things due to
malnutrition and yes he kept jars of
urine at this point we don't know much
about Mindstorm or his powers only that
he fought alongside soldier boy in
Nicaragua Soldier Boy tells them that as
long as they don't look into his eyes
they should be fine since Mindstorm has
the ability to hear people's thoughts
and unleash their greatest nightmares my
greatest nightmare is a brony convention
after an entire episode maeveless it's
revealed she's still alive after having
been captured by homelander in black
noir homelander found out about May even
her plan to bring him down and black
noir wanted revenge for Maeve almost
killing her with an Almond Joy the door
holding her in almost looks Fit For A
blank Vault but I guess it makes sense
considering maeve's tremendous power her
body completely smashed through a
security truck in season one homelander
wants to know where Butcher and Soldier
Boy are hiding but she's quick to notice
that he's wearing concealer I need a
concealer for zit last episode we saw
homelander bruised for the very first
time a result of the fight he had with
the boys proving that he can be hurt the
aftermath of hirogasm Saw seven soups
killed and the ones who survived lose
their power similar to how Kimiko lost
hers after being blasted by soldier boy
in episode 4. this might explain why
termite wasn't able to transform back
into his human size he no longer had the
ability to do so just like Soldier Boy
wanted kids with Crimson Countess
homelander says he once dreamed of
having kids with Maeve their child would
be twice as strong as Ryan remember that
Ryan is The Offspring of a soup and
human not two soups he makes a note that
if he ever does have a child they won't
grow up in a room like this a room he
himself grew up in after all the
experiments done to him by Jonah
vogelbaum and Vaught homelander keeps
Maeve around so that he can eventually
Harvest her eggs but if he really wanted
to he could have killed her and done
that days ago does he want to see her
suffer or is there still some humanity
and love for her deep down inside
regardless Maeve notes that this is the
first time she's ever seen him scared
after their brutal encounter with little
Nina last episode Kimiko and Frenchie
show up at MMS last episode I talked
about how this place was furnished with
photos from the Civil Rights era and
here we see more including Huey Newton
the founder of the Black Panther Party
and above him the 44th President of the
United States Barack Obama fun fact on
Karen fukuhara's YouTube channel you can
see her and Laz Alonso who plays mm do
an ASMR video on this exact set butcher
has connected the dots on what makes
Soldier Boy spawn spontaneously explode
it's his PTSD marijuana is one of the
few things that helps ease his anxiety
however this seems to have an adverse
side effect of paranoia would you say
what the [ __ ] did you say Butcher and
Huey comment on how bad it is that
soldier boy is doing drugs yet they
themselves proceed to shoot up some temp
B here's our first shot of Buster
beavers kind of Chuck E cheese rip-off
that you can actually see a commercial
for on vot news now this is probably an
old Wendy's they converted into Buster
beavers judging by the curved sun room
the restaurants were known to have at
least here in Canada where the show is
filmed did you guys have the same thing
in the U.S by the way it was Buster
Beaver who blocked Noir was drawing when
homelander so graciously got them taco
bowls this is smooth delicious this
place looks like it hasn't been touched
in years this is likely the exact
location black noir paralyzed a young
boy in the ball pit when he was nine
years old maybe that's why it's in such
disrepair and no one wants it but owning
this building as evidenced by the for
sale sign leads me to believe this
incident is what LED black noir to be
adopted by Vaught where he would go on
to become a member of payback over some
delicious Vaught chili Buster beaver and
a host of other animated creatures tell
black noir he can't go on hiding from
his past they helped him get through the
Hard Rock Cafe incident in Lagos they
can help him get through this what black
noir did to that Hard Rock Cafe and
Lagos should be brought up on war crimes
on their way to Mindstorm we can see the
effect that temp V has on Huey and for
that matter butcher whose ear oozes out
this black goo perhaps coagulated blood
from the brain this is the same type of
Goo Huey discovered in his ear last
episode a tripwire detonates knocking
Soldier Boy and butcher but before
butcher can come too he's put into one
of mindstorm's nightmare Comas the only
person who can get him out of it is
Mindstorm himself soldier boy exclaims
that most of mindstorm's victims fall
into this state and simply die of
dehydration as their mind succumbs to
their own nightmares and Soldier Boy
threatens Huey with a Sean Connery slap
which is a a reference to his Infamous
interview with Barbara Walters in which
he stated slapping a woman is okay you
think it's good to slap a woman I don't
think it's that bad I think that it
depends entirely on the circumstances
and if it matters it so bold strategy
cotton let's see if it pays off for him
in his mind butcher relives his greatest
nightmare the story which led him to
feel guilty for his younger brother
Lenny's death we've seen Lenny haunt
butcher multiple times throughout the
season here we see young butcher
protecting his brother from their
abusive father a father we saw an older
version of in season 2 played by
denethor as he navigates this nightmare
we see how his memories of the past seep
into the present day like how Lenny
symbolizes Huey and his rage for his
father was taken out on gunpowder
Frenchy laments missing out on hirogasm
I mean I would too and it's here we
answer one of my biggest mysteries from
last episode how come the halothane
didn't work on Soldier Boy well it turns
out it wasn't halifane at all rather a
vapor version of a deadly Russian nerve
agent What would would kill any regular
human merely knock Soldier Boy out and
in order to get this agent they may need
to travel back to Russia not sure if
that's going to happen or if this means
we'll see The Return of little Nina
Frenchie notices mm's OCD this time with
a cigarette on the ashtray we saw this
last episode before mm arrived at
hirogasm with his tapping of the
steering wheel and we'll also see it
later in this one with his drink Shaker
as Starlight helps bandage a still
wounded Kimiko Maniac featured in the
movie Flashdance plays there sure are a
lot of Maniacs in this show and it
foreshadows kimiko's crazy idea to have
any injector with compound V in order to
get her powers back and it's kind of
crazy she has a kirkland-sized bottle of
whiskey having her first drink ever with
Starlight funny enough you can actually
see Karen who plays Kimiko make
cocktails with Starlight on her YouTube
channel which I'll leave a link to in
the description below Kimiko has a big
ask of Starlight to obtain some compound
V from Vaught Tower she wants her powers
back because she never wants to be in a
position of being unable to save some
someone she loves this all seems part of
kimiko's realization that she can no
longer run away from the past Huey
confronts Soldier Boy about his lies
regarding the beaches of Normandy a
comment which sees him promptly get
punched in the face to him soldier boy
is just like the Marlboro Man a
manufactured image of these strong
masculine American which is nothing but
a facade in fact one of the actors who
played the marble man for 12 years
didn't even smoke the Deep has pulled
out all the stumps to sway Cassandra to
invite someone else in the bedroom an
idea she isn't particularly interested
in especially considering that someone
is an octopus named Ambrosius the Deep
really be going from Eaton one to being
eaten out by one needless to say this
little sexcape does not go over well
with Cassandra and she storms off
telling the Deep he can run his business
on his own remember that Cassandra has
been instrumental in positioning the
Deep back into the seven so it'll be
interesting to see how things derail for
him without her help and for the love of
God Cassandra get her pronouns right
okay son it's a her get your pronouns
right this would not fly at meeve's
inclusive Kingdom black noir's animated
Forest Critters recreate a formative
event in his life and give context to
why he agreed to Stan Edgar's plan to
take Soldier Boy out black noir was set
to play Axel Foley in Beverly Hills Cop
but soldier boy had Don Simpson the
producer of the film cut him from the
job funny enough Don Simpson also
produced Flashdance which we saw on the
TV during the Starlight Kimiko scene all
the other members of payback are here
too in animated form and witnessed the
absolute brutality Soldier Boy inflicts
on black noir this gives some context to
what Crimson Countess said to him in
episode 5. I hated you
we all did I forget if it's been
mentioned or not before but we get
Soldier Boy's real name which is Ben and
I love how black noir is portrayed as a
black sheep because he's kind of like
the black sheep of the seven keeps to
himself and is quiet back in butcher's
mind we can see that it's the year 1989.
a butcher is reprimanded by the
Headmaster for selling marijuana but
when the Headmaster says he doesn't want
to see him turn out like his father he's
promptly bashed in the head with a
stapler and his father is like well
sometimes people need a slap I think
it's absolutely right on their way to
Mindstorm Soldier Boy and Huey come
across a nun and priest and we get a
little more insight into how crazy
Soldier Boys paranoia is everyone's
coming for us everyone every day he's so
out of it he shoots the priest believing
him to be mind controlled by Mindstorm
which might actually have been true
considering that none will surprise
attack yui in one of the most cryptic
scenes in the entire episode homelander
seems to express both anger and sexual
gratification as he hears Starlight on
the news at least that's the vibe icon I
got we did see how he has this kind of
alter ego defense mechanism from last
episode so maybe this is two sides of
him kind of duking it out to show how
truly unhinged he is at a Robert Singer
rally who you may remember met with Stan
Edgar at the beginning of the season to
discuss the military's potential use of
temp V homelander touts more conspiracy
theories about how Starlights Run Away
Home for teens is being used as a
pipeline for human trafficking on vot
news we've seen how other soups like
Maeve have similar youth centers
homelander also jumps at the opportunity
to blame the media for not reporting it
turning the crowd against them
reminiscent of a trump rally media
Outlets like CNN and MSNBC are fake news
Victoria Newman isn't too pleased that
homelander isn't using this time to
promote singer as the new president I
also like how he's running against Ted
Cruz it seems Victoria has a vested
interest in singer becoming president so
she interrupts homelander and tells him
he needs to get his [ __ ] together she
knows soldier boy is back and he better
do something about it but homelander
doesn't take this too calmly I think
it's absolutely right and Victoria
reminds him she can help him and hands
him a piece of paper at the end of the
episode we see what is written on it 715
County Highway 2 Aldrich Minnesota I
think this is where his son Ryan is
being kept if you remember back at the
end of season 2 Ryan was put into
protective custody and his whereabouts
unknown to homelander it could also be
where soldier boy is but my money is on
Ryan if homelander ends up going to Ryan
it may result in a showdown with butcher
giving him the opportunity to mend his
relationship with Brian recovering after
his heart attack a train is back Tower
having received blue Hawk's heart as a
transplant in fact Ashley says this
heart will allow Atrium to heal back to
normal they even have him set to Star
alongside Tom Hanks in a movie about a
white guy teaching a black guy on how to
quote unquote be civilized it'll be
written by Julian fellows who all the
boys fans will know as the writer behind
Downton Abbey we also get our first look
at Senator Lamar Bishop who the show
might set up as Robert singer's vice
president on screen you can read another
q Anon conspiracy about adrenochrome
which is a drug Q Anon followers believe
is harvested from the blood of children
by Hollywood Elites mother's milk finds
out his daughter is at a Robert Singer
rally with her stepdad Todd Todd is a
huge homelander fan loving his unhinged
speech a few episodes ago and even
dressing up as him for Janine's birthday
Kimiko asked Frenchie to dance with him
it'll be the last time she can feel him
for real as she states that when she was
on V it didn't feel the same they danced
to Ella Fitzgerald's Dream a Little
Dream the same song Kimiko dreamed of
singing way back in episode episode 1
she tells him about her plan to take
compound V that she never wants to be in
a position where she can't fight for
those she loves Starlight breaks into
the science labs at Vaught Tower and we
can see vials for both the original and
temp V versions I don't know about you
guys but they have the worst security
here Maeve alone has smuggled like
dozens of these vials out more
concerning however are the notes
scribbled down about the side effects
including brain lesions atrophy of the
cortex and death between three to five
doses Butcher and Huey are definitely in
that range through animation we learned
that black noir was given the order to
capture Soldier Boy by Stan Edgar and
that this order actually came from
someone even higher than him at VA I
believe this person to be Frederick
fought himself now Stan says it's to
make room for a new superhero homelander
who at the time would be three years old
the second part of the scene can be seen
in live action in episode 3 but
something to me just isn't adding up why
sell them off to the Russians the US's
mortal enemy why not just kill him
either black nor are wanted to see him
suffer or something more is going on
here in my episode 6 breakdown I
theorized that Frederick Vaught had a
personal Vendetta against Soldier Boy
for having sex with his wife Liberty I
founded it in 52.
I mean this other Liberty man was she a
firecracker but war with the Soviets
also means good business for vot having
a super that could nullify other powers
could equal the playing field between
the U.S and Soviets something Vaught
would want so there's arguments to be
made here on why bot would want him
alive or dead we also bear witness to
the origin story of black noir's
disfigured face something he got while
taking on Soldier Boy with the rest of
payback when his head was smashed into a
fiery truck this may explain why he
doesn't speak he probably lost the
ability to with the amount of brains
that came out of his skull its Crimson
Countess who latches the nerve agent
onto Soldier Boy's head allowing him to
be transported Away by the Russians
Buster Beaver tells black no more that
he has to be brave and take on Soldier
Boy no more hiding out at this abandoned
kids play center mother's milk confronts
Todd about putting Janine in danger he
believes that anywhere homelander is is
dangerous considering soldier boy is
after him but Todd sees all this as fake
news he's been indoctrinated did by vot
news propaganda and after he makes a
snide remark of mm not being there as a
father mm punches him that seems to be a
theme this episode lots of punching at
Vaught homelander confronts Starlight
she says she's here collecting her
things to leave but homelander reminds
her what would happen if she defies him
that he'll go after Huey just like how
he went after supersonic so he wants her
to recant everything she said he can't
kill her just yet because she's
America's sweetheart and her death would
seriously hurt the one thing he wants
more than anything the love of the
people but Starlight says she isn't
scared of him anymore he's just a small
man and it's revealed the whole
conversation was recorded on her live
stream poor Ashley's gonna have a hell
of a time spinning this one Huey and
soldier boy have tracked Mindstorm to an
old cabin where sensing an opportunity
to save his friend Huey teleports a
Mindstorm back to butcher making a deal
for a butcher's life in exchange for
Mindstorms he'll teleport Mindstorms
somewhere safe FIB Mindstorm gets
butcher out of his coma in butcher's
final flashback we learn how he left his
brother to go and join the Army
essentially leaving him with his abusive
father justifying it by saying that if
he stayed he'd end up killing his dad
and butcher is pretty brutal here
telling his brother it ain't his
responsibility to look after him butcher
has a history of being really mean to
those closest to him not only that
butcher never came back to check on him
resulting in Lenny being pushed to
Suicide Lenny tells him that anyone
who's ever loved him ends up getting
killed him his wife Becca and
potentially Huey this is especially
concerning considering at the end of the
episode butcher tells Huey they need to
get more temp V knowing full well from
Starlight it could kill them now this
could go two ways either butcher is so
blinded by his hatred for homelander
that he'd sacrifice himself and Huey to
kill him or that he has a different plan
involving temp V altogether what would
happen if homelander were injected with
dozens of injections of temp V would his
brain turn to Mush especially if his
powers were to get nullified honestly
I'm just inhaling copium at this point
because I don't want to see butcher Ray
Huey Soldier Boy arrives and gets the
upper hand on Mindstorm interrogating
him on why Vaught would give payback the
green light to kill him we can't quite
hear what Mindstorm says but it'll be
revealed at the end of the episode I
also wonder if Stan Edgar would be on
Soldier Boy's hit list too Starlight
tells Frenchy and Kimiko she's going to
save Huey even if he doesn't want me to
if I have to hear about Starlight or
Huey saving each other one more time my
head is gonna pop harder than
alistairadanas Starlight gives Kimiko
the compound V which Frenchie
administers and it restores her powers
we might see them take on little Nina
next and try to acquire that nerve agent
Butcher and Soldier Boy are a bit
traumatized after today's shocking
events there's a crimson Countess movie
poster for a film called whiskey sunrise
in the background which could be a play
on the actual movie Tequila Sunrise
homelander receives a call from none
other than soldier boy and what might be
one of the show's most shocking reveals
yet in the fall of 1980 soldier boy was
called into Dr vogelbaum's lab to do
experiments involving genetics Soldier
Boy supplied some of his soldiers sperm
and nine months later in the spring of
1981 homelander was born something that
was Kept Secret from him the funny thing
is soldier boy says he would have
stepped aside as vaught's Golden Boy if
he had known homelander was his son
remember soldier boy has always wanted a
kid and homelander never really had a
good father figure so I wouldn't be
surprised if these two team up we also
don't know who homelander's mother is
I've theorized that it could be
Stormfront especially considering how
she essentially disappeared around 1979
could she have been under Dr vogelbaum's
care and injected with Soldier Boy's
sperm to create the Ultimate Weapon
homelander after all Stormfront is one
of the strongest soups so mixing her
with soldier boy makes sense now this
also begs the question of whether or not
she knew that homelander was her son was
her memory wipe did she think the child
died did she ever not see him again
there's just so many unanswered
questions but at this time the craziest
theory for me is that Stormfront is
homelander's Mom and yes that means home
Lander banged his mom now there are a
few images from the teaser and trailer
that we haven't yet seen in the show
which might give us some Clues as to
where things are headed this is your
warning if you don't want to be spoiled
the first is homelander being greeted by
adoring fans it looks like these are his
die-hard fans who don't care about what
he said on starlight's live stream
there's a soldier boy statue toppled
here so maybe there's been actual proof
to the people that he's alive and is the
terrorist who's been blowing up these
places across the country the toppled
statue could mean homelander and Vaught
are villainizing soldier boy but behind
the scenes actually working with him
we'll see this shot of Starlight and
mother's milk taking on soldier boy but
if you look closely in the corner here
you can make out two figures which could
be homelander fighting Maeve this seems
to take place at Vaught news so it would
be crazy if this fight was caught on
camera for the world to see forgive me
if I'm wrong but I don't think we've
seen this image of black noir sharpening
his knives in the vot boardroom perhaps
he's preparing to take on soldier boy I
also want to bring up three things that
have haven't really been addressed that
may come up next episode where is Stan
Edgar what happened to Victoria Newman's
kid who she gave compound V to and
what's going on with Ryan I'd place my
money that all three of these will
somehow be addressed in next week's
finale but what do you think I want to
hear your thoughts and theories in the
comments below remember to like And
subscribe so you're notified as soon as
my finale video drops you can also
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
this is yourself